welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka better called
Paul because my real name is Paul should
probably call myself that and set a
definition anyway better call Saul has
just wrapped up on Netflix and as always
there's a lot to unpack from it the
fifth season has really stepped up to
the plate and it can be argued that it's
now on par with Breaking Bad in terms of
quality season five marked a number of
things and a left elements wide open for
the future throughout this video we're
going to be going through the ins and
outs of the season and giving our
thoughts on it there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to watch it yet then I highly
suggest that you turn off now make sure
you subscribe to the channel for
breakdowns like this every day and
please drop a thumbs up if you love
Jimmy McGill without the way thank you
for clicking this now let's get into a
breakdown of better call Saul okay so
season 5 brought a lot with it and
there's a ton of things to talk about I
just want to stick to the main plot in
finale but throughout the season there
were a lot of major events that
definitely should be touched upon
firstly Jimmy started practicing law
under the name Saul Goodman and he
managed to build a big clientele base
through the mobile phone network that he
built in the prior entry pun intended
there we also got the return of Hank
Schrader and his partner Steve Gomez I
know this is a prequel and technically
they haven't returned but it is good to
see them back this was their first
meeting with Saul and as we know the
pair will cross paths with him in a
major way during Breaking Bad this will
ultimately lead to their demise down the
road and I'll never forget you Hank
Kim started to enforce a home eviction
for her client Mesa Verde in order for
them to build a call center she
genuinely tried all that she could to
get the property owner to budge and even
turned to Jimmy in order to help Jimmy
now fully in the sole persona went way
too far and he put him in a really
compromising position eventually she had
to leave her law firm and in the end
things did work out but there was a
point where Kim made Jimmy promise that
there would be no more lies the two even
got married and this was tested early on
in the seminal episode bagman in that
Jimmy ended up collecting seven million
dollars in bail money
for his cartel client Lalo it was a
phenomenal entry that I think fans of
the show will remember as a standout
episode for a long time
and I loved watching him trudge through
the desert with Mike as they were slowly
chased by sicarios I don't know if
that's the correct usage of Sicario but
I wanted this sound cool anyway Jimmy
and Kim on the only main players now
either what I love about this season is
that nacho Gus bring Mike and Lalo all
get their own story lines that really
flesh out the narrative and put things
in place for Breaking Bad there's a real
Cold War feeling to the entire piece
with nacho now working as a double agent
but Frank and the Salamanca's time and
time again he's forced to prove himself
and he doesn't have much choice in the
matter as Gus has a literal gun to his
father's head now there is an excellent
moment in which Mike tries to talk us
out of using fear as a motivator in
order to control someone he begs and
pleads with him stating that it
ultimately always goes bad but
unfortunately it falls upon deaf ears
this would of course later come to bite
us in the butt in Breaking Bad in which
he tried to use the same tactics against
Walt and things turned out bad for him
the entire theme of the season is
centered around how lies can end up
spiraling out of control and almost all
of the characters are hiding something
at some point Mike's relationship with
his granddaughter almost falls apart
because he lies about what happened to
his son and her father Gus is tested
several times as he keeps up the facade
of being a team player nacho is in a
lose-lose situation due to his
unfortunate position and Jimmy
well Jimmy just lies throughout whether
it's to Howard his wife Lala he just
can't seem to stick to the truth his
lies with Lala will come back on him and
in episode 9 he went to see Kim and Jim
personally however surprisingly the
former lied for Jimmy and she managed to
do it really well
initially Kim started off as a genuine
person wishing to obey the law but we've
seen throughout the season that she's
slowly been corrupted by the sword
persona and is becoming very similar to
him I'll discuss this more in detail in
just a bit but there are some amazing
parallels between the two such as their
actions and mannerisms which show that
she is slowly becoming her own version
of Saul I love that to start the season
when she was questioning whether the
soul persona was that there
person in their relationship and we see
her go through a similar Rock throughout
season 5 episode 10 picks up with the
pair having just sent Lalo packing and
in what feels like the first honest
moment in the season
Jimmy confesses to Kim exactly what
happened out in the desert I honestly
think that she knew or at least had an
idea of what had happened but she still
acts slightly shocked and comforts him
this is an example of the mask that Kim
wears and similar to Jimmy she is now
playing a part when really she has most
things figured out Jimmy asks if he's
bad for her and I think the audience and
Kim both know the answer deep down here
was a budding lawyer that has been
completely changed due to her
relationship with Saul and even though I
love the two you do get the feeling that
this is only going to go one way the two
retreat to a luxury hotel and spend the
majority of the episode hiding out in
the location the fact that it's so
high-end though not mentioned does
highlight to me that they feel like
they're on borrowed time so they might
as well live it up Kim still has things
to attend to though and she returns to
the courthouse where she encounters
Howard he tells her about all the things
that have happened to him in the season
such as balls being thrown at his car
and while his balls being discussed in
public however rather than being shocked
by this or even apologizing she laughs
at him and finds it insulting that he
would insinuate that Jimmy was behind
her departure at her law firm upon
returning to the hotel she decides that
they need to work together in order to
mess with him these pranks initially
start off as innocent like shaving his
head and putting Niro in a shampoo
however they gradually increase until
they start planning to get him disbarred
the conversation is mainly led by Kim
and she's actually the one who elevates
it and not Jimmy I don't know if I'm in
the minority but I actually quite like
Howard and I kind of thought that he was
wrongly made the villain by Jimmy
especially when it was revealed that
chuck was the one who was actually
behind a lot of the misdeeds that were
pinned on him they decide to humiliate
him which will force him to step back
from the Sandpiper case which will make
all-party sell quicker and nurse those
involved will get their money quicker
after learning that they are safe they
decide to frame him for something
unforgivable which is of course the
episodes title but it goes beyond that
the fact that they agree on coming up
with this
deme that's really gonna mess up how its
Korea showcases just how far Kim has
come
Jimmy asks if Kim could be okay with
doing such a thing and she responds with
the Saul Goodman gun fingers cementing
that she is now truly an extension of
the alter ego now what will happen to
Kim with just one season left well we
don't know for certain
and even Raya Sehorn told The Hollywood
Reporter today that the creative team
haven't finalized the ending of our arc
we do know one thing though Kim and
Jimmy are not together for Breaking Bad
and whether it's death or divorce things
are gonna go badly for the pair how do
you think that it will be the latter
purely because I think that watching her
die would make Jimmy leave everything
including his persona behind the fact
that he still works in law likely shows
that soul lost Jimmy or Kimmie in
episode 10 saw even packs his bags
because he realizes just how bad he is
for her I think next season will be the
final straw for the pair and I really
hope that Jimmy does the right thing
because it's sad seeing what Kim has
become elsewhere is Gus who in the wake
of the saw of false flag attack on his
own restaurant decides to send assassins
after Lalo which leads to a big action
scene for the finale this takes place at
the Salamanca compound and Gus uses his
Inside Man nacho to let Frings forces
into the fortress the plan is to go
ahead when everyone is in bed however we
learned that Lalo doesn't really sleep
much
and he only requires one to two hours a
night in order to be fully rested up
watching that show slowly play out the
social situation while the clock ticks
down is brilliant and he cunningly
starts a fire within the house to draw
Lalo away whilst he breaks one of the
padlocks at the home using a fall
technique I didn't even know about this
but if if my bike goes missing we know
what happened
natural runs off into the night and now
we don't know what his fate will be he
at least survives the season which I
actually wasn't expecting him to
mirroring this lalo to makes it out
alive after showing firsthand just how
good he is when it comes to a fight seem
like Gus had everything set up after
arranging his release from prison
allowing him to travel to Mexico and
then putting the hit on Lala's on
doorstep in order to draw a suspicion
away from him but he didn't count on
Lalo being the man that he is I
absolutely love
the tunnel scene and it shows just how
prepared he was for this kind of
encounter he takes out the assassins and
questions the final one over who hired
the hit Gus was smart and instead used
the middleman but Lalo still knows the
truth obviously the two are going to war
and you might have some questions over
what happens to the character well it
does seem that Lalo might actually
survive until a certain point in
Breaking Bad if he's not killed in the
next season when Saul is kidnapped by
Jesse in Walt he starts to beg for his
life and state he's always been friends
with the cartel when they seem confused
he says Lalo didn't send you and seems
quite relieved now this could show that
Lalo does survive at least until this
point I do you think that Jimmy would be
keeping tabs on him as he will no doubt
be worried about his return so it is
possible that Lalo does survive the
events of the next season
however he definitely does die either
before or by season four of Breaking Bad
this is confirmed by Gus who visits
Hector and states that every other
Salamanca is dead which does suggest
that he indeed comes to his demise at
the hands of the character overall it's
a brilliant way to end the season though
and I can't wait to see what happens
next time the pieces are all in place
now for a big finale but there is one
thing hanging over Jimmy's future that
is what will he do now that he's been
recognized in a flash-forward he was
spotted by a random member of the public
though he did initially want to be
relocated in the end he decided against
this perhaps he is going to find a way
to silence the character or he may
finally be accepting over the fact that
it's time to stop running Jimmy is a
character that I think will get his
comeuppance and who knows what will
happen in the future now before we get
into the review I just wanna let you
know we're giving away a free copy of
the Marvel phase 3 pot 1 box set to one
random subscriber all you have to do to
be in with a chance of winning is like
the video subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on the show in the
comment section below the winners gonna
be chosen at random on the 15th of May
in the cell to be shipped out from the
intro ever gets the prize it's the best
of luck to everyone who takes part okay
so what did I think of the show overall
well I absolutely loved it and it's easy
to see why it's getting so much praise
everyone seems to be really enjoying it
right now and it's for a good reason
finally all of the pieces are falling in
place and I'm so glad that all of the
Breaking Bad characters are getting
expanded roles here the show has heart
drama and action and it's a blast to
watch I love Netflix releasing episodes
weekly to as it really helps you digest
what you've just watched and it's better
for me getting to sit with the program
for months rather than just having to
binge it in a weekend overall I love
better called soul and it gets a 9 out
of 10
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the show so comment below
and let me know if you want something
else to watch them make sure you check
out our breakdown of too hard to handle
which is gonna be linked at the end if
you want to support the channel from as
little as 99 cents a month then please
click the join button below
we massively appreciate you and as a
thank you you get access to content
early you want to come chat to us after
the show either follow us at definition
whitey or click the discord link in the
description below those the best ways to
keep up to date with heavy spoilers so
hopefully we see over there very soon
this is a channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
you
[Music]
[Music]